có thể thấy tươi rất xin quả hải cả bày toàn tiếp tóc cục
Được này, thì ăn chí high có bảy đến thăm thời khá nhường
Bảy chí sẽ bật bản là có một số anh chỉ
Nào bây giờ của ta tiếp tục cơ khá nửi tiêu
Tươi đến chơi thì cang chí chí sẽ như này này
Ngày xưa tại sao mà anh chỉ thật là con là tiếp tục cơ
Lã anh chỉ cũng chia sẽ lại cái quá trình mà
Học với thầy dụ nhìn kiếm mềm, nhớ nhỏ hoặc là những cái bài dặn nhớ nhỏ
Sao anh chỉ, ăn bình thích tóc, một giết lên thế khác
Hãy video nhé khẳng hiểu tướng tác, tướng đẩn đẩn đẩn đẩn trị, quen và cách tạm đi theo mặt dù ra,
gặp bẩy thôi nhưng mà của là KWLQC, và gánh trị đường thường sẽ bảo mặt tình như vừa ra,
cho nó gánh trị.
Hai, lưỡi bản đảm ả mạ nắm mình.